The solar system appears to be a perfectly tuned mechanism when viewed at large,
by contrast,
there's a real realm of chaos between the orbits of Mars and Jupiter.
This is where hundreds of thousands of small celestial objects was around space
in all sorts of directions, occasionally crossing other objects, saw bits.
They sometimes get in each other's way and produce thousands of shards and bits
on collision with this area of space, highly changeable.
It is hardly possible to predict what it will look like in the distant future.
Of course, we'll be talking about the main asteroid belt,
one of the most changeable and mysterious areas in the solar system
today over 300,000 small celestial bodies found here have been given
names and numerical designations. Interestingly,
there overall number may well reach over a million.
The starting point of studying the asteroid belt may be defined at 1801.
When astronomers spotted a mysterious object in the sky,
after a long and hard search for the fifth planet, in terms of its parameters,
it appeared to be a planet,
but happened to be so small that even the advanced telescopes of the day
couldn't distinguish its disc,
the researchers saw the newly discovered object as a bright dot, like a star.
It was dubbed series.
And very soon similar celestial objects of this class were discovered and new
term had to be introduced to refer to them.
These unusual astronomical bodies came to be called asteroids,
which literally means starlike apart from asteroids.
This area in the solar system contains great amounts of cosmic dust while
slowly spiraling up its tiny particles, scatter sunrise,
and create a very faint wide glow.
This glow is referred to as ODI light. Interestingly,
in equatorial areas of the earth,
it can be seen with a naked eye for a long time.
The following hypothesis used to be widely accepted asteroid belt objects
with thought to be debris of a destroyed planet. However,
today this assumption doesn't really hold water. First of all,
the mass total of all the objects of the main asteroid belt is due small and
equals just three times 10 to the power of 21 kilograms or
4%, the mass of the moon,
even allowing for the fact that the greater part of asteroids would've left the
belt a while ago,
the total mass of the rocket debris debris is still falls short of making up an
object with dimensions comparable to those of a proper planet. Secondly,
estimates show that large celestial objects cannot form in this area of the
solar system on account of Jupiter's gravitational influence,
mathematical modeling revealed that the largest formations in the asteroid belt
have never measured over a thousand kilometers in diameter.
The gravitational influence of their mighty giant neighbor rendered their RO
bits, highly unstable,
which made potential proto planets collide and disintegrate into smaller bits
traces of these collisions can still be observed most objects of the main belt
grouped together to form the so-called asteroid families,
populations of asteroids, of similar makeup and of the same origin.
It is thought that they formed as a result of such destructive collisions.
The borders of the main asteroid belt are rather Lud.
Most of the objects making a up lie within 2.06 to
3.27 astronomical units from the sun.
These boundaries are predefined by Jupiter's title forces and are referred to
as Kirkwood gaps, any celestial objects,
getting into these zones experience, the massive gas giants,
strong gravitational influence, which destabilizes their orbits.
This is the reason why the space object count here is considerably lower than
beyond
Kirkwood gaps can be found not only on the conventional borders of the belt,
but inside it two,
two of the most clearly defined gap light 2.5 and
2.82 astronomical units away from the sun.
The asteroid belt is also conventionally divided into two large areas,
inner and doubt about the border between them is a Kirkwood gap
with a radius measuring 2.5 astronomical units,
which coincides with the orbital resonance with Jupiter it's in the
outer part of the main belt that the largest object in this area of the solar
system is situated series.
This celestial object used to be thought a planet then an asteroid,
but eventually in 2006, it was given the status of a dwarf planet.
It was possible to do so. Thanks to the fact that sir has a spherical shape,
unlike the absolute majority of the other objects and the belt,
its diameter measures around 940 kilometers and its mass
9.4 times 10 to the power of 20 kilograms,
which incidentally accounts for around a third of the overall mass of the
asteroid belt.
This makes series approximately 6,000 times lighter than now. Planet.
The furthest point of the dwarf planet's orbit from the sun is 2.9
astronomical units. When series is at its per Heian,
the distance to our system center measures around two and of astronomical units.
At this point,
the planetoid surface temperature may reach 239 Kelvin or
33 degrees. Celss below zero.
Although its average temperature is noticeably smaller at just
167 Calvin or 106 degrees
celss below zero.
The Celest till body is thought to be made up of a Rocky core enveloped in a
cryo mantle around a hundred kilometers thick water ice accounts for up to
half of the dwarf planet's volume or 20 to 30% of its mass.
The inner part of the belt harbors the largest and most massive known asteroid
in the solar system vest the objects average
diameter measures, roughly 525 kilometers.
And its mass is around 2.6 times 10 to the power of 20 kilo,
which is almost four times as little as that of series.
The asteroid orbit is rather elongated with its EIL
2.57 astronomical units and its Perian around 2.15
astronomical units away.
It takes this less still body 3.6 earth years to complete a full orbit a
around the sun vest is also remarkable for being the only asteroid
visible to the naked eye.
It can be seen not only on account of its impressive dimensions,
but also thanks to its comparatively light surface that reflects about 42%
of light shed on it.
Besides the minimal distance between Veta and the isn't that great
at just 177 million kilometers or 1.18
astronomical units,
it is assumed that Wester is a fully fledged planet in terms of its inner
makeup.
It appears to have a metallic core made up of nickel and dying as well as a
Rocky mantle.
The surface temperature of the as is currently fluctuating between minus
190 and minus 20 degrees Celsius,
but it used to be much warmer in the past dark areas to be seen on
the surface. And the Western hemisphere are highly likely to be Beal planes.
Such terrain features may have formed as a result of volcanic activity or
collision events were with massive astronomical bodies.
The most outstanding geological feature on the asteroid is the giant impact
crater referred to as RIL whose diameter measures up to 500
kilometers. And its depth is around 25,000 meters.
The second largest mountain in the solar system is sit shaded at its center
towering higher than 22 kilometers impressively.
The crater diameter almost equals vests size.
It looks like the asteroid collided with a really large object.
At some point in the past,
the collision would've produced not only the rear Sylvia crater,
but also a great of small bits, which are now classified as the family of vest,
numerous asteroids,
the family counts over 15,000 objects making up around
5% of all celestial bodies of the main belt known to science today.
It is positive that most asteroid families came to be as a result of destructive
collisions of two large celestial objects.
Sometimes the debris debris are mutually attracted by gravity forces,
which usually blend them into a new astronomical object. However,
it would've lost its monolith nature and sometimes astronomers
informally call such formations rubble piles. For example,
Sylvia,
one of the largest objects in the asteroid belt seems to fall into this category
of celestial bodies.
Its parameters are 384 by 262 by
you hundred and 32 kilometers with a mass 1.5 times
10 to the power of 19 kilograms.
This makes asteroids average density just 20% higher than that of water
estimates show that cavities may count for 25 to 60% of its volume.
It takes six, five years to complete a full orbit around the sun.
The objects orbits furthest point from the center of the system is up to
3.7 astronomical units in its Perian.
Sylvia gets as close to the sun as 3.2 astronomical units.
It is assumed that some bits of debris left after a collision are not attracted
to other bits, but rather become satellites of the new celestial body.
Sylvia is known to have two such companions Romulus with a diameter
measuring 18 kilometers and Remus measuring around seven kilometers.
Their makeup hasn't been studied yet,
and it is highly that these objects are not monolithic either.
Besides Sylvia may theoretically have smaller satellites as well,
which haven't been detected yet.
Palace is another remarkable object in the asteroid belt.
It was discovered back in 1802, right after series.
And is the second asteroid in the about the average diameter of the
celestial body is around 512 kilometers.
And its mass is roughly two times 10 to the power of 20 kilograms,
which is approximately 25% less than that.
Veta the asteroids orbit is exceptionally elongated and
tilts to the ecliptic plane at 35 degrees.
That is the reason why the astronomical body is so hard to investigate with
probes as for its orbital period.
It takes palace around 4.6 years to Orbi the sun in the course of which
the distance to the system centered changes more than one and a half times with
its Perian 2.1 astronomical units,
its ahe is 3.4 astronomical units away palace's surface
is widely pocket marked with CRAs much more so than the largest series
of vest studies of the chemical composition of the asteroid surface reveal that
it mostly consists of silica TRX with small amounts of iron and water,
just like vest.
This celestial body is thought to be one of the few potential proto planets that
are still around,
which means that studying it may yield important information about the formation
process of the solar system. Unlike Fe,
most asteroids can be seen either with the naked eye or through amateur
telescopes.
One of these elusive objects is called inter Ramia admittedly,
one of the most mysterious objects of the main asteroid belt.
This is an irregular shaped asteroid with parameters
362 by 348 by 310
kilometers and its mass accounts for roughly 1.2% of the
overall mass of all objects and the belt in spite of its relatively large size,
however, and Tarran near remains larger understudied.
One of the difficulties thwarting scientific progress here is the asteroids dark
surface, which absorbs around 93% of light shed on it.
Inam near falls into the exceptionally rare spectral class F,
which is a subclass of carbonation asteroids research with
reflection shows that the color of the celestial body's surface is even which
means that Inam near, hasn't experienced big collisions for quite a long time.
Inam nears D is not that great at just twice that of water.
The asteroid is thought to be made up of a hard Rocky core enveloped in a thick
layer. White, the surface is covered with great amounts of fine dark dust.
It takes an AMIA around five years and four months to complete a full orbit
around the sun.
Its EIL is on the opposite side from four largest objects of the main belt and
the distance from the asteroid to the sun varies from 2.5 to 3.5
astronomical units. In theory,
Inam orbit crosses the trajectories of such large objects as series and palace,
but estimates show that chances of their colliding with each other are small.
There are millions of objects in the main belt from dwarf planets to tiny
meteoroids the size or co however distances between them
measure thousands upon thousands or even millions of kilometers.
That is why spacecraft crossing the belt would be running an almost negligible
risk of getting hit by any astronomical body.
Still mathematical modeling shows at around once every 10 million years
summary marketable collisions take place in this part of the solar system that
produce new debris debris,
even though a mound mission to asteroids in the main belt will not be in the
pipeline for a long while.
Some of the asteroids there have been studied with a help of interplanetary
space probes. For example,
the Dawn probe carried out observations of series investor in the period from
2011 to 2016. Quite recently,
the space probe Lucy blasted off the surface of the earth,
even though it's main go is the so-called Jupiter Trojan.
The spacecraft will approach the object known as Donald Joe Hansen in the main
belt and take its pictures in 2025.
Also the launch of the psyche project is scheduled for July,
2022 with the largest known metallic asteroid of the main belt as its target
within the mission.
The probe is plant to reach his destination by early 20,
26 and remain in the asteroid belt for at least 21 months while studying
the asteroids terrain, makeup and magnetic field.
Small though, they may be asteroids are important,
both from the scientific and practical point of view.
Some main belt objects are real treasure troves dating back to the early stages
of the solar system formation studying them will give us clearer insights into
processes of how planets and other celestial bodies form and in the future,
asteroids will make sources of materials for space exploration.
We don't know when we will be ready for this,
but every new rocket launched in a space brings the space era slightly closer
and every new like you give us brings a nice new video closer let's keep
in touch.
I.